I got to meet Drew Brees man
I got to meet Drew Brees I went to the
Super Bowl the other day I was over
there with David Spades and y'all know
David Spades okay one of my heroes and
all one of America's Heroes
I mean he's the damn Davy Crockett of
humor
um
and he invited me over to a party he was
a fundraiser
they're raising funds and
um so we go there and it's nice there's
like
there's like rich people and somebody's
somebody was like being real rich and
then somebody was next to him and they
were
you know
so they started crying and the other
person's like don't cry you're rich you
know so people were just being [__]
rich in this place and
um
and so we walk up and Blake Shelton is
there
and I like Blake Shelton man uh like
Blake Shelton
um
he is an Oklahoma guy
and he uh you know he just sings and
he's comfortable man and I've met him
before
and uh and I I like him I like him
so anyway we walk up Blake Shelton is
playing it's like it's like the part in
the evening at a party where somebody is
playing music so everybody kind of half
has to be quiet
and we walk up and there's a guy Steve
Mariucci okay he's a uh coach
he's a coach and I want to say he's
Italian I'm not trying to be racial or
anything but
That's Italian you know and he looks
Italian you know he looks like if you if
you tickle him he'll [__] just he'll
tell you all the ingredients of a
cannoli even if he doesn't want to you
know he just has that that look to him
and
I walk up and he Steve Mariucci is
talking to Drew Brees and I've had
dreams in my life my head where I'm like
how do you meet do you ever meet Drew
Brees does God want you to ever meet
Drew Brees
you know does Mother Nature is there
ever another flood and one of y'all gets
flooded right up next to the other one
and you get to finally meet
um
and so there he is and I would and and
so when you're with David Spade David
Spade can kind of just go up to anybody
and like be like
and people are like happy about it so
I'm just kind of Milling around in the
distance being like
hey look at David Spade and um
and so anyway he walks the speed walks
up and I just kind of like in his shadow
like kind of there but hiding but trying
to be like confident like okay how do I
how do I walk up to Drew Brees you know
do I look like uh
do I look right at him do I kind of look
you know at the moon like what you know
how do you do it do I you know put my
shoulders even do I kind of like be like
one shoulder is heavier
do I
what do I do you know and I was nervous
man and so
David kind of starts joking and they're
both excited to see spade and they're
talking to him and I'm right there and I
know at some point it's coming around
that Spade is going to introduce me so
I'm like what do you know how do I how
do I look when he's like hey this is the
owner like to buy smile do I
so I don't know what to do so I open my
mouth right which is insane I think
that's an insane
you know you're me okay I got his mouth
open and then
I put both hands out like this
like if you know if you ask somebody how
long is something they say oh about
one foot long
that's what I did he like
David introduced me to each guy and I
it was almost like you had given
somebody
uh it was almost like that guy maybe in
what's the sport Maybe
uh
is that
rugby or Cricket when the guy does
that you know anyway so I did two hands
died two hands shaked Mariucci and
and Breeze and so out the gate I'm like
oh God this you know I'm not doing that
good
hey I'm not doing good you know and I
started just kind of praying for myself
um
which you're not supposed to do I know
that
you know you're supposed to pray for
others uh but I did I I needed I needed
it and I was right there and I'm like
what do you say when do you say
something do you say anything who are
you are you someone that says something
soon or are you not
do you just listen do you laugh
how loud do you laugh do you laugh you
don't want to sound like a fake you know
uh so anyway I'm just being alive
and um
and Breeze is dialed in bro when you're
talking to him
he's like you can see in his eye bro he
could play for I think another
I think he could play for another 20
months in the NFL
well
he's just he's so locked in like you're
talking to him and you can see he's
watching like where the waiters and the
bus boys are going you know he can see
the
um you know that one of the waiters is
running an out route to go on a smoke
break he can see that the bus boy did a
curl but you know short of the sticks
you can I mean he's like
he's caught you know he's got an audible
he's got Colston going but there's
everything he's he's monitoring
everything
while you're there talking to him he is
dialed in
he is dialed into life
and you don't even know if Drew Brees
blinks that's how he he blinks when you
blink
he sees you blink so that's when he
that's when he blinks he ain't missing a
moment
he's locked in
and it was interesting because
um I asked him I said hey did you guys
ever play against each other him and um
Mariucci right
and uh
and Brees was like yeah we sure did and
if he ratted off the date he rattled off
the score
um
and you could just I mean he is just an
anthology
of uh
of precision
is kind of how I would describe it as
much as I got to you know I I I got to
talk with them for maybe about 10
minutes
total
and maybe a 90 seconds I could kind of
feel my arms and legs uh while I was
doing it
so a lot of time I was just pretending
to you know have a stable
um
uh what's it called when they oh pulse
the whole time I was talking to Drew
Brees I could see him just
he was always every now and then he
would glance in the distance and just
see if Deborah Henderson was open
so anyway that's a lot about Drew Brees
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one